Cross validation is a great tool, but
the typical usage of it doesn't fit
financial data applications well.
The reason is that it can
permit peeking into the future.
So for instance, if our training
data is after our test data
that means we're seeing
the future ahead of our test.
Any sort of peeking like this can read
to unrealistically optimistic results,
so with this sort of
data we need to avoid it.
One way to avoid this problem is
with role forward cross validation.
That means our training data is
always before our testing data.
But we can still have multiple trials
just by rolling our data forward,
like this and this and this,
till we run out of data.